oui jo aujourd'hui nous sommes réunis
pour commémorer la vie et les services
de la reine elizabeth ii c'est avec ces
mots que le directeur de la british
school nicolas samon débute l'hommage à
la reine elizabeth ii le responsable de
l'établissement ensuite invité les
élèves à respecter deux minutes de
silence pour la monarque
le décès de la reine a forcément
provoquer de l'émotion dans cette école
britannique implanté à croissy sur seine
depuis les années 50 d'un côté je suis
triste mais d'un côté je suis content
parce que moi je sais qu'elle allait
elle est au paradis avec son mari sa
mère et son père avant cette minute de
silence j'en ai j'en ai utilisé pour
faire une petite prière
en rendent hommage à la reine
d'angleterre je suis pas vraiment
anglaise du coup je sais ça ne sachant
pas énormément d'importance pour moi
mais je vois que ça ça a beaucoup
d'importance pour mes amis du coup je
suis là pour les supporter pour être là
pour eux au total 600 élèves et
professeurs se sont réunis pour cet
événement de quelques minutes en
parallèle les drapeaux ont également été
mis en berne et un drap noir a été
déployé autour du tableau de la reine
située dans l'un des bâtiments de
l'établissement aujourd'hui est un jour
triste mais c'est un jour où nous
pouvons nous tourner vers l'avenir
à rennes à la télé ça via notre service
est elle était une fausse pour la paire
nounours jeunes buvant beaucoup
apprendre de son exemple le procès de la
british school of art s avec la roue et
charles et la famille au roi la reine
n'est jamais venu à la british school
mais certains élèves de l'école avaient
rencontré dans les années 90 les
responsables espèrent pouvoir accueillir
un jour le nouveau roi charles iii